hey everyone Steve on trope with
Collider I am overjoyed to have Damon
Lindelof in studio today to talk about
Watchmen before you even say a word I
want to say on camera HBO HBO has
blessed me by letting me see the first
six episodes of this show it is
incredible I can't believe what you did
with the material and it's it's really
in this age of amazing television this
show stands near the top it's just so so
well done so anyone who's watching this
who has any debate about watching this
show you need to watch well I really
appreciate you saying that
thank you yeah that's I needed to start
with that thank you I want to start I
want to jump backwards and I want to
talk about what was it how did you first
meet with HBO to discuss making this
show was it one of these things where
you heard they were thinking about it or
you went in and said something I I've
had a love affair with Watchmen since
since I first read it I was 13 years old
and have talked about it sort of
incessantly since I've been blessed
enough to move into the pop culture
sphere so in between the first and the
second seasons have lost but I was
getting you ask questions like oh my god
you're doing nonlinear storytelling and
you're you do flashbacks and there'll be
a pass every episode is a different
character and I would say I learned that
all from Watchmen I mean just so we're
all clear I that I stole from Watchmen
and watchman is the greatest piece of
popular culture ever created and and one
of the most exciting things to come out
of Lost was that that quote meets me
saying the the Watchmen was the greatest
piece of popular culture ever created
God blurbed on the back of one of the
Watchmen trades and I was just like oh
my god my my name is on the back of the
Watchmen trade and what a thrill that
was so words sort of got out that that I
was a huge fan of this thing because I
was talking about it incessantly and so
when Zack Snyder made his movie I got
pulled into you know one of these early
screenings where Billy Crudup is covered
in all sorts of like ping-pong balls and
Moke
you know as sort of like the wah you
know the the Watchmen literate and so
over time basically I think probably the
first time that it happened was around
2011 I had an overall deal with Warner
Brothers and someone over there
approached me and said hey would you
want to do Watchmen as a television show
and my feeling at that point was Zack
had just made the movie that the
Watchmen is considered unadoptable and
unfilmable Alan Moore who I should say
is a genius and I'm only sitting here
because of him not because just because
of Watchmen but I learned some so much
writing he does not want you to watch
Watchmen so if you are a few are a more
acolyte please honor his wishes that
said I was sort of like Alan Moore
doesn't want anybody to do it pass like
it shouldn't exist and then a couple
years later again from Warner Brothers
and and and obviously they have all this
DC IP sort of came back and said hey you
know what about Watchmen like you said
no a couple years ago have you thought
any more about it and I said I have and
and and still no and then as the
leftovers was ending this time Warner
Brothers sort of with HBO they're now
they've been under the same corporate
umbrella for quite some time but they'd
obviously been talking to one another
now as the leftovers was ending I again
sort of fielded the inquiry of you know
like okay are you sure you don't want to
do anything with Watchmen and now the
sort of parenthesis was we're gonna move
on like we're gonna start asking other
people to do this and at that point I
started realizing this thing is gonna
happen whether I do it or not and I know
that it's a moral justification to say
well I'm a vegan but that steak is
already there the animal is already dead
so if I don't eat it it's just gonna rot
that's that's that's BS like but ice but
but I I started to feel the professional
jealousy of what was it going to be like
for me to see someone else's watchman
knowing that I had a
at it and I didn't take it and then also
I started to feel like I had the
beginnings of what the ideas might be to
go into this watchman and so the third
time that they asked me I said let me go
give it a think and then kind of here we
are two years later and it exists I am
so thankful that you decided to say yes
I think everyone watching as they watch
the series will be saying the exact same
thing well we shall see I mean I'm very
confident on this 1k so you started
having those ideas you started thinking
about it did it always did it always
walk down the path that the series ended
up on or did you have radical other
ideas that almost came to fruition I
think the central ideas are are in this
series I think that the idea of of what
happens when masking sort of spreads to
policing that was a big that was a big
part of it the the idea of how we feel
in America about policing right now and
and and the institution of the law in
authority all felt very timely but it
also felt like a very natural
progression from the central ideas of
the original Watchmen which were you
know who watches the Watchmen you know I
think that a lot of people who are not
really familiar with the with with the
original 12 issues or they'll call it
the graphic novel although that name
that designation came later one of the
one of the questions that it was asking
is what is the line between the law and
vigilantism when is it okay to go above
and beyond the law and so I felt like
that was a central tenet of of Watchmen
and now the 2019 that I was living in
was constantly questioning and doubting
the intention and ability of police and
more importantly the government that was
responsible for policing the police and
so all of those ideas felt just as
relevant now as they did in the mid 80s
but it but it felt like there there was
an evolution to be had there and so that
central idea
fanatical II really took hold and then
the other was that just sort of all
around me was the feeling of like there
was a reckoning happening in the country
as it related to race this idea of that
there is a history of the United States
that it was taught to me as a sort of
middle class a border you know a
borderline privileged kid living in
northern New Jersey in this in this
incredibly sort of diversified community
but a utopic to some degree and then the
actual United States history that is
like as I'm starting to read more I
always knew that slavery happened duh
there's Black History Month you get that
month but then everything else is kind
of hidden and as I started but most
specifically reading what Tallahassee
Coates was writing and in the and I just
have to full disclosure I have to say
that I started reading Tallahassee
Coates because that's what white
liberals in Los Angeles are supposed to
do and when we have our whoa coughs when
we're you know it's all about what
podcasts we're listening to and who's
read the most Tallahassee coats so I I
kind of went to church with the
intention of saying hey I went to church
today but in this case when I read the
case for reparations which was an essay
of his in the Atlantic I that was the
sermon that I heard that suddenly
changed my entire perspective on the way
that I saw the world and in that essay
he mentioned black Wall Street that the
Tulsa massacre of 1921 and I felt
ashamed and embarrassed that I had never
heard of it I didn't know anything about
it I did somehow considered myself an
educated person who was somewhat of a
history buff interested in in in in the
history of race in the past century and
and beyond and yet I didn't know what
black Wall Street was so I bought a book
called the burning that tells the
detailed story of that and I was reading
that book at the time that this this
watchman invitation happened and so all
of those things were starting to swirl
around in my brain and they started to
feel like they might combine into a
television experience it's crazy how
that all came together because the
things you're talking about are so
important to the
series and are handled really powerfully
man I have one there's so much I want to
talk about I'm trying to avoid spoilers
and uh so I'm gonna switch completely
and say what did you learn making the
leftovers that you could apply to making
Watchmen that's a great question I mean
I guess sort of like the short answer is
that is that the bandwidth for a show
the frequency of tone requires a certain
degree of experimentation and there's
something to be said for you I got very
locked in on what I thought the
leftovers was so I read Tom Piratas book
and I was like this is about grief and
loss and despair existential despair
from which there is no escape and it's
just that and I was really interested in
telling that story because that was an
emotion that I wasn't really seeing a
lot on TV and I think it resulted in the
first season of the leftovers which was
all of those adjectives that I just
mentioned and people even people who
liked it would like would say to me like
I really liked the first season the
leftovers but it kind of made me ill and
I was like thanks and as we moved into
the second and third season of the show
in particular particularly because the
writers room I started listening a lot
more to what other people had to say
about what they saw when they read the
leftovers or even what they saw when
they saw the first season in the show
and they said we think that there's a
lot of space for absurdity and we think
that there's more space for genre
borderlines sci-fi storytelling and I
was like no the sudden departure is the
only weird thing that happened and
they're like but the but the perception
of what could be weird and and the
mistaking of miracles feels like there's
space there too and so I stood suddenly
realize like the leftovers can it be
funny you know can it be absurd let's
try and so coming into Watchmen I feel
what I learned is that not to get locked
in on what I feel the the the very
specific there's only one frequency we
can tune into here there's actually a
lot more bandwidth and more importantly
to listen more and I feel like that's
really hard it's easy for me to say like
I listened to the other writers that's
always my intention
but it's hard when someone else is
talking to say to your own brain shut up
you're just waiting to say the next
thing that you want to say you're not
really listening you're not really
creating a space for their idea to
flourish you just want their idea to
support whatever your next idea is and I
went through that process on the
leftovers and I think as a result the
second and third season of the leftovers
became this incredible thing that didn't
feel like mine anymore it felt like ours
and I really feel that way about
Watchmen too that happened very quickly
but it stopped being mine pretty quickly
started becoming ours because we
obviously all had different
relationships of the source material and
we're finding the new thing together but
I do think that that was a really
valuable lesson that that I that I
brought into Watchmen I did you when you
started coming up with the idea and
you're you're figuring it all out were
you thinking at all about budget in the
creative process knowing with all your
experience what things cost and how much
were you sort of like I'm just gonna
write it and then I'll think about the
budget both I mean I think that we
certainly had ideas after having done
lost first and then the leftovers that
obviously there was a shift in scope so
lost even though it was on broadcast
television they gave us a tremendous
budget one that I was really grateful
for the entire time we were making that
show that was very far above and beyond
a traditional broadcast budget and then
though and then when we did the
leftovers obviously it was an HBO show
but I think everybody understood that
this was kind of more of a you know an
artisanal pizza and so the idea that it
was never going to attract a very wide
large audience
it just wasn't scaled that way the
budget had to be reflective of that but
at the same time we wanted to be
ambitious but we were constantly having
budget battles with Watchmen
nobody said to me we're gonna write you
a blank check but in our early
conversations about what the scope of
the show was gonna be and as I said HBO
just know that this is a century show as
the original Watchmen took place in the
range between the late 1930s and the mid
1980s this show is going to start in
1921 and it's going to and it's going to
take us all the way to
20:19 and it might not necessarily all
take place on the planet Earth so I just
want you guys to know going in that the
appetite and the ambition and the scope
is more lost than it is leftovers in HBO
was like we totally get that and
conversations about what the actual
dollar amount would be didn't really
come in into play until they got the
pilot script and we budgeted it out and
then they started to realize okay when
when he said that the ambition was high
wow it's really high but I will say in
their defense and again not in their
defense because they don't require
defending but when we would ask for
things like Trent Reznor and Atticus
Ross for example is like these are movie
composers these are a list composers
they're gonna they've never done TV
before it's gonna cost it's gonna cost
to get these guys there were no converse
they were never like there were no money
conversations as soon as they heard the
trend Atticus may be interested it was
like let's go get them
and buy do I have to say their music in
this is extraordinary it's a character
yeah I mean they they actually they're
watch what happened was they were like
which composers might you be interested
in this and for this and from project to
project I always like to change
composers because it forces me to be a
little bit outside my comfort zone so
even though Michael Giacchino is a
genius it didn't feel like he should do
left overs and even though max Richter
is a genius it didn't feel like he
should do Watchmen and so HBO was like
who are you thinking and I was like well
well Trent Atticus they don't do TV but
it this show feels to me like it sounds
like them and then there was like an
awkward pause on the other end of the
phone and I was like oh they don't agree
with me and Francesca or see the
executives Bo said that is so weird
because their manager called me two
hours ago and said what's going on with
Watchmen like give me the room with
those guys so I sat down with with
traumatic Asst and try it like try not
to you know like they're there I get
starstruck but they're rock stars and
they're SuperDuper cool and like
normally like you you you you can't kick
out too hard and I was like we have to
get this out of the way I just
worship and adore everything that you've
ever done and you're amazing and then we
all started kind of talking about
Watchmen the original and what it meant
to them and by the end of that meeting I
was like this is gonna be incredible and
about a month later I just got a huge
file of music the turn Atticus had done
and said hey look we know that you
haven't liked you you've just written
the pilot and you haven't shot it yet
but we when we read it this is kind of
what we were thinking and uh I'd say
like 90% of the music and the pilot was
in that first piece of material before
we've even shot at and so Nick Nicole
Castle Cassell and I we would listen to
it on the set you know and and it
informed the actual shooting of the show
the music came first is what I'm saying
yeah the music is so good I'm there
they're super I'm curious so you you get
in the writers room you put together
this staff
how many scripts did you have before she
how many scripts did you have before the
shooting began you had the pilot and
then right so we actually put the
writers room together about a dozen
writers before the pilot was written
just to do the world-building because we
knew that everything in the original
Watchmen was canon so we were kind of
covered through 8680 late 85 and that we
needed assistance to build a new history
between December of 85 and basically
September of not 2019 which is the front
story that the present time for for our
Watchmen in addition to carving out
spaces in the pre-existing history of
the the the the previous Watchmen
because our story actually starts in
1921 in Oklahoma and so we had to do a
lot of work over the course of that time
period and in that time period we also
broke the pilot episode and then I went
off and wrote that we hiatus the writers
room we shot the pilot and then we and
then HBO watched the pilot and said okay
we're gonna go ahead and order the
series and then we reconvened the
readers I have to ask you did you ever
think after making the pilot that they
were gonna turn it down or constantly oh
really
yeah yeah oh yeah constantly and
I like I have a you know very
complicated relationship with the work
and I you know that we're having this
conversation right now three days before
it is shown on HBO and I still and like
does it work like my own feelings about
the show there are parts of it that I'm
immensely proud of but those are the
parts that feel like the least mine it's
constantly like I have a very
complicated relationship with it so
while I feel like Nikki did an
incredible job directing it and the cast
did an incredible job
acting in it and the costumes were cool
and the music sounded awesome and it was
shot beautifully and the production
design was impeccable and everybody
brought their a-game I was sort of like
I don't know I don't I don't know if
this works and that's not me being
modest or being a pessimist it's just
the way that I felt so when HBO called
and said like oh my god were into this I
was like immensely relieved and
surprised and also sort of like oh my
god we've got to make more like
fortunately we had a plan sure because a
lot of the work that we did over the
course of those that that first writers
room we had we had we had said this is
this is what the season would be not the
first season the season because one of
the things that I think makes the wat
makes the original Watchmen endure is
that it was a complete story beginning
middle and end over the course of those
12 issues and when I finished reading
the 12 issue the 12th issue of course I
want to wanted more because I loved it
so much but I also felt like a sense of
of completed mess and I want the
audience to have the same sense watching
watching these 9 episodes so to answer
your question we dope that into the
writing and we had we had basically an
episodic plan for what episodes 2
through 9 would be and the first thing I
don't know where we are in spoiler
territory but I can't know where
spoiler-free essentially well I can't
say this and this is spoiler free which
is that Jeremy Irons is sort of kind of
in his own show inside of the show of
of Watchmen now they're there they're on
parallel tracks and eventually those
tracks will come smashing into one
another I promise that but we shot all
of Jeremy's work in Wales and it needed
to be completed before the weather
turned and so the first thing that we
all wrote as writers were nine episodes
worth of material for Jeremy Irons so we
had to have a real plan in motion for
how that would weave in with the other
story because we wrote all that and we
shot that first up and so before we
wrote episode 2 we wrote all of Jeremy's
work episodes 2 through 9 that's crazy
and he's it's his stuff is what I've
seen if his stuff is so good he's off
the job oh yeah what he's doing is it's
amazing
so you basically knew you knew where you
were going the whole time we're like the
final shot was gonna go where the where
the where the ending of this story would
go yeah yeah I mean you know getting
there getting getting to the destination
getting to what the last it you know
what the last episodes gonna be you know
a big part of of the original Watchmen
and the way that I like to tell stories
and watch stories is what's the pace at
which you answer questions and resolve
mysteries and again that's an imperfect
science I've I've learned over time that
it's that it's not an exact science but
so we knew the answers to the a lot of
the questions that the show is asking
but are we going to answer them in
Episode six are we gonna answer them in
Episode eight maybe we do this one in
Episode seven but to answer your
question there's some stuff that could
only happen in the finale so I think
that we knew more about how the the
season was going to end and then we did
about some of the things that were
happening in APIs in the range of
episodes sort of like five through eight
completely um you've said one of the
things that I love about what I've seen
so far and what you've just said is that
this show does have a beginning middle
and an end but I'm telling you as
someone who has seen the first six
episodes and know
what I've watched and the quality of the
writing and the quality of the
production designed the music everything
I have a feeling that you're gonna stick
the landing and I have a feeling that
fans of this material and of this show
who maybe have not read the comic book
are absolutely gonna hope that you have
more or another story that you might
want to tell in this world are you is it
something that you can't even process in
terms of do I want to touch the third
rail one more time or is it something do
you know what I mean I know exactly what
you mean and it's something that I'm you
know really thinking about for the first
time in any real way because this week
that you and I are talking is like
really the first week that I'm kind of
finished with the work we're still doing
a lot of sound work and a lot of his
effects work to finish up the final
couple episodes but I'm more or less
finished and so but more importantly I'm
in you know now that the show is about
to come out and I'm doing press for the
show people are asking okay so what
season two gonna be because that's the
way they were programmed I mean that
makes complete nutter sense to me and
and and for me it's sort of like I I
have to anticipate the question but I
really wasn't thinking about season two
as I was making season 1 so it's
basically like every good idea that we
have that's worthwhile is going into
this season and I wanted to I don't want
it to feel like well we'll pay that off
later or like oh don't worry about that
one like every story we're telling let's
pack it into these 9 episodes and so my
feeling is is like like obviously
Watchmen is not mine you know that's
what's beautiful about it and and
someone else can take it can take the
reins in the way that for comic book
fans of which I consider myself one
first and foremost the the idea that you
know Alan Moore himself came to Swamp
Thing in the early 1980s and he
basically completely and totally
reinvented that character but that
character was not his creation and then
and then us someone like you know Brian
Vaughn could come to
swampthing later or Jeff Lemire and and
do their own spin on the character
that's what Watchmen should be so I'm
not entirely sure that I should do
another season because we're kind of
what keeps it fresh is that it's sort of
a new vision if I had the right idea I'd
certainly be open to it but I haven't
had that idea yet when you talk about
sticking the landing that's yet to be
determined
my hope is that at the very least people
will be like it was really awesome
watching that dive even if he belly
flopped listen I have a funny look you
can't have such the first six episodes
are so good that I have a lot of faith
in you guys that you are gonna stick it
but I I mean the thing about it is
though I hear what you're saying but I
also think that if the ratings are very
strong and the reaction is very strong
and thus far everything I've seen has
been very strong I would imagine HBO is
gonna say well we want to do another
story sure I look I mean I agree with
you I think that unless you have the
right take on it it's like you know
don't ruin something awesome right you
know what I mean but I think a lot of
people are gonna really hope you have
something to something more after this
if you know but who knows maybe it needs
to stand on its own yeah and and I think
that I agree with you but and but I feel
like everything particularly in this in
this world that's very franchise heavy
very sequel heavy very it's it's all
about pre-existing IP etc etc and I get
that I consume all that stuff and I love
it and I think that there's this really
exciting space now for original
storytelling you know inside of the
world of pre-existing IP that said we
should always start with a question
should we you know should we do this
let's not just do this because we can
get a lot of people to buy a ticket or
to tune in because they have a
pre-existing relationship with Watchmen
or the Joker or Ironman or a black
panther like we should be asking
ourselves should we you know should we
tell this story and then if you have a
good if your answer to that is yes then
the follow-up question is be like why
you know and you should be able to
answer that question too and if you
can't answer it then don't do it I'm
always wondering
I won't bring but I look at Joker like
I'm not one off but do you ever think
Dark Knight Returns will ever get
adapted you know what I mean as a movie
or like a 8 episode HBO show you know
the Frank Miller I mean I would watch
the hell out of it sure if any interest
in that no because because the reason
that I don't have any interest in it is
because that's that would be a
straight-up adaptation right where
you're basically taking something that
already Frank Miller already wrote and
illustrated and is perfect and you're
basically you're bringing it to life and
an obviously Superman is gonna be in it
and if you're if you're literally doing
Dark Knight straight-up but there but
all you're basically doing is is
adapting something and what made Dark
Knight so amazing and revolutionary was
that it was so original and
groundbreaking and so when it's just
about you can sort of it's like the the
dance instruction where the where the
where the painted feet are there on the
ground and you just have to hit the
right steps like I would just be
terrified of messing it up and more
importantly like I want a freestyle well
I'm not the guy for that but I I wanted
to exist and I would watch it I I I'm
wondering it just at what point that
actually happens because as you I agree
with you it's so original so brilliant
it came out so close to Watchmen right
very weird that both of those things
came out so close together yeah I'm you
know I think it would be really
interesting to wait for somebody like
you know Michael Keaton who who has
already done Batman or a Christian Bale
25 years from now and then do Dark
Knight with them so it's someone who we
actually saw play a younger version of
Batman that would be that would be rad I
completely agree how long did you have a
lot of deleted scenes on the show on
Watchmen do you have a much longer first
cuts or is it pretty much what you shot
is what's on screen the first cuts are
always way too long because we're we we
overwrite the show and over shoot the
show but it's but like in the honing
down in the tightening of the episodes
that's part of the process I think you
know in the in the pilot there's only
there's only one
deleted scene which is actually like
sort of the header of the scene that
ended up in the show so there's nothing
that we shot that didn't air in some
form but you're always sort of like that
line of dialogue is completely and
totally unnecessary don't need it I'd
rather I'd rather stay here then get to
Cuddy so you find you know you find the
rhythm of the show as as you edit but I
think that universally speaking the the
tighter it gets the better it gets
sure is there do you so for the whole
nine episodes would you consider that
there's like any deleted scenes that
ended up not making it that are like
worth people seeing or not really
they're half there there has to be one
or two I just literally can't think of
anything sure I mean like we were pretty
you know back to your earlier
conversation about budget and schedule
when you have a show this ambitious I
think to me that the most the worst
thing that you can do is make the crew
go through the exercise of going out to
some location for a day and 300 people
and actors and and cinematographers and
directors are working to basically
execute the scene to the best of their
professional ability and then it doesn't
air so you want to make sure at the
scripting phase that everything feels
absolutely and totally essential and so
as we start boarding the show you know
how are we gonna schedule this thing and
fit it inside twelve or thirteen days of
principal photography you know that's
when you have to have the first
conversation of what is essential and
what is not essential and used that
that's when I think the cutting happens
that's when the deal that's when the
deleted scenes occur like we didn't we I
have to get back to I'm really hard
pressed to think of anything that we
shot that did not that is not going to
hear did when did you you have to have
heard by now from like okay who did you
show the pilot to or any early episodes
for like honest feedback or did you not
do any of that in terms of like just
getting a feel from maybe people that
had read the comic or not read the comic
and watching it just to tell you because
it's not like making a movie where you
can do these big test screenings right
you know how did that work I mean
outside the immediate sort of Warner
Brothers HBO family
I was really reluctant to to show the
show to anyone because bye-bye time the
pilot was like was mixed and finally we
were already like kind of shooting
episode 8 I was like if if we show it to
people and they hate it you know what
are we gonna what are we gonna do like
it's almost and and I I would I don't
want to I sometimes get frustrated by
the idea people who want to show you
their stuff and they just want the stamp
they just want to be told that it's
great they actually don't want the notes
and I was like I don't know what I would
be able to do with the notes at this
point so I probably should have done
what you're describing but I think that
there was like the huge level of fear of
like oh my god what if someone watches
this thing and says that it's just sort
of like morally reprehensible on on
every level
sure so I will say that that that Ed
Brubaker who is is a friend and
colleague whose work I tremendously
admire and and is someone who has an
encyclopedic knowledge of Watchmen and
is a huge sort of like Alan Moore fan
and believes very strongly and
everything that Alan has said about
Watchmen I was like I kind of feel like
I want Eddie to see it not to give me
the stamp but if if someone's gonna say
to me this is an abomination and and I
you just need to know you just need to
prepare yourself for what the fans are
gonna say what the Watchmen fans are
gonna say I knew that he would be honest
with me so I showed him the the pilot
and he was like you are AI all-in
paraphrasing like you are in way over
your head here but I think I kind of
love it like and so I was like okay cool
like I'll take that that's that's that's
a fair assessment yeah you yeah did you
ever think about doing more than 9
episodes or was it did you come close to
10 or 12 the original plan was to do 10
and and as we started plotting out the
episodes it started to feel like we were
getting into that territory where one of
them was gonna be filler like it was so
clear to me
what at
that the the pacing wanted to be very
explosive in the pilot we wanted to stop
and kind of recalibrate in episodes two
and three and then and then and then
episodes four five six very specific
ramp into like kind of a white-knuckle
seven eight nine but as I started to
feel like what was that when the tenth
episode was the finale and I started
looking at it at the roadmap that we
were gonna take to get there I was like
it feels like we're kind of driving 40
miles an hour here in these mid-range of
episodes what if we just pull this one
out and we do nine then everything
really started to click so we ended up
with this I mean I'm sort of really
curious about this idea of like how many
episodes is a season of television now
what's the perfect number what's just
right and the answer is it's completely
and totally arbitrary we did 25 hours of
lost in the first season and 17 in the
final season and and the experience of
making those seasons of television was
based on we'll be able to keep the
quality bar high with the less episodes
that we make and then as we went into
left overs we did ten ten and eight and
people were like why aren't you doing
ten episodes in the final season and I
was like cuz it felt like the right
number people might forget though that
with lost it was very early on that you
guys were fighting ABC to try to get
less episode right and a lot an end-date
yeah yeah I mean a lot of people just a
lot of people don't realize that because
I think that you had it you you knew I
have so much story to tell and I don't
need 25 episodes a year to tell it right
seriously congratulations on the show
thank you so much for coming in I really
hope everyone watching this right now
tunes in it's it's what I've seen so far
as growing up thank you man I really
appreciate it and and I hope you like
where it ends up I'm confident